this is a story that's gotten more
attention lately but still less than it
deserves it says desperate mothers
across the u.s have been forced to buy
formula they know will make their babies
sick as the country grapples with a
shortage that has left shelves bare and
has caused prices to skyrocket to 120 a
can 120 dollars a can
i mean think about getting into your car
to drive to the grocery store you got to
put gas in your car for 450 a gallon or
whatever it is now and um and then
you're driving to the store and you're
paying and twenty dollars a can for baby
formula
this is simply not a sustainable
way to live for most americans
uh winter bathrobe of gals in tennessee
says she broke down inside her car after
driving to six stores and calling others
as far as three hours away only to
receive the same answer which is that
the specific formula
uh that her baby needs and tolerates was
out of stock when it dawned on her that
she would have to feed her baby girl
blakely um
baby girl blakely non-hyper
hypoallergenic formula she knew she
would uh make her make her stomach sick
the new mother bursts into tears and
then they give many other examples of
this major retailers such as cvs
walgreens and target have a limited
in-store and online purchase up to three
per buyer as parents have raised
concerns that many are hoarding the
already hard defined formulas this is
something i noticed myself i was at
walgreens yesterday in fact and they had
the formula
behind the counter behind glass
and i watched somebody come in and they
got their ration of formula so we we are
now in in a a position of baby formula
rationing
and um now
we're not in the market for baby formula
but this is something and you know when
i go to buy diapers you see it as well
the shelves are almost entirely bare
and this is a a real
crisis
so much so that i'm not exactly sure
what you do as a parent now i know that
um
you know there's some people that have
commented and said well there's a
there's a cheap there's a free
alternative to formula which is
breastfeeding and obviously yes but
some mothers can't breastfeed
you know for various different physical
medical reasons
they don't have enough supply
uh there could also be you know there
are plenty of mothers that actually have
to work especially given the state of
the economy right now and so what do you
do in that situation when you can't find
formula
you know we were in that position with
um even though my wife's a stay-at-home
mom with our twins
uh just because of supply issues and and
and and uh other other things we had to
supplement we had no choice we had to
supplement the breastfeeding with uh
with baby formula
and especially with twins we bought a
lot of it
and i know from experience that babies
have
you know very specific needs when it
comes to that and you're going to find a
certain kind of formula that they need
if you try to give them something else
they're going to have gas they're going
to get colicky they're going to be up
all night screaming
and this is what um
people are facing just just one this is
this is one of the
major crises gripping the country and it
is a crisis
and i think it should tell you something
that although it's a crisis
when this is food for infants
that we're running out of
um
although it is a crisis there's not a
whole lot being said about it especially
from the corporate media
i mean they're
they're paying lip service to it because
they have to
they went a while without reporting it
at all now they're reporting it because
they have no
choice but they're mostly trying to
ignore it and part of the reason for
ignoring it obviously is that it makes
biden look really bad it's just yet
another major problem that we're facing
since biden came into office and um they
don't want to do that because he's their
guy
but
i think it's also just that
for a lot of people on the left
especially uh especially if they're
childless
they just don't feel
any kind of they don't really feel
anything about a baby formula shortage
in fact for a lot of them they're more
outraged about
college-educated adults
having to pay their loans their student
loans
then about babies not having enough food
to eat
have we heard anything from the squad
about the baby formula problem because
we've heard a whole lot about the poor
you know the poor 30 year old
college graduates with graduate degrees
who now have to pay their student loans
back
and what a crisis that is
what about infant children that can't
can't eat because they don't have enough
food
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content